hey guys so I wanted to talk about this
common confusion that keeps coming up
over and over and over again we'll
drinking bulletproof coffee break my
fast okay so when you're doing
bulletproof coffee you're actually
adding MCT oil and butter and sometimes
people just add whole cream and they
consume this they blend it up and they
consume it okay now if you actually
check the blood sugars after consuming
this bulletproof coffee it generally
will not raise the sugars and most
people on some people it might but
generally it won't in fact it might even
raise your ketone level okay so it
actually helps you produce ketones but
here's the thing we have to look at the
definition of what does it mean break a
fast because if we look at the
underlying goal for most people they
want to know not if it breaks my fast
but is it going to stop me losing weight
okay so I think that's a better question
and it's going to stop you losing weight
because your body is going to turn these
into ketones okay and use that as fuel
and not have to tap into its own reserve
and use your own fat as ketones and is
for fuel so to summarize the question is
will it break my fast well not if your
definition of breaking the fast is
raising the blood sugars but it will
slow down your weight loss because your
body doesn't have to produce its own
ketones it can rely on the ketones of
this now okay I hope that clarified that
so we've been getting a lot of success
stories but I don't have your success
story yet so click the link down below
and upload you before and after I want
to actually hear about your success
story I want to see your
before-and-afters and every week we do
featured success stories so click the
link down below and share your success